Let's now try to bring back some of the details on how images are captured from
these cameras, and try to get into some representations of how mathematically we
can look at all of these.
Here we basically start off with an image that we want to capture, and
this is my sensor.
As we looked on the image processing and image representations, most of
the time we represent an image in this form with x and y, or columns and rows.
Of course the 3D world has this coordinate axis, Y up X, and Z which could be
sometimes, in this case, be respective as we go down into the scene.
So imagine if this is my object in the scene,
what would it actually look like in a 3D camera?
So to help us kind of get into understanding this kind of concept of
a camera model, let's imagine I have an object in this 3D scene.
To help us, we will actually unwrap this.
And now I'm showing the Z-axis, and this way X and Y, so
I've kind of turned it around and looking at this scene from this direction, and
that, that basically is the way I'm looking at it here.
So this is my object, and again shown here.
Basically, I'm just going to give it some value, X, Y, and
Z, which basically is this point here of this object.
We can basically look at all the values, so X is this,
Z is this, sorry Z is, Z would be this value.
X is this value and Y would be up how high this object is.
Of course the tracing the ray through and imagine this to be a pinhole, so
this is my pinhole of the camera itself.
Ray goes through here.
And of course on the other side,
I should be able to now think about where the image will be formed.
We'll get an inverted image on that side there,
and of course it's on that side of the X axis.
And this would be the value in the image plane on the sensor.
And it's my sensor, this is where the image forms on that side of the camera.
So the camera pinhole is here, the sensor is here, 3D scene is here.
We know that, of course, the sensor should be at the focal plain.
Now using similar triangles we can actually start finding out
more information about where the values of this would be.
The similar triangle basically says that the ratio of xi over f,
which is xi over f, should be the same as X-non which is this value here.
So xi is this and focal length of course is this.
Similarly, X0 is this and in place of f we have the Z value here.
So xi over f is equal to X-non over Z-non.
And similarly for y, we can do the same thing and come up with this equation.
We can simplify this to now be able to get the values of xi and
yi with this relationship.
So as long as I know,
of course, the, how far the object is from the scene and where it is, I should
be able to now figure out where the pixel value would be on that image itself.
Of course, we not, not all the time do we know these values from the real word,
especially just from an image.